hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
es wird wieder Zeit für Sallys fünf
Minuten weil jetzt gerade Spargelsaison
ist gibt es natürlich Spargelrezepte von
mir
heute möchte ich euch ein Spargelrezept
machen nämlich weißen Spargel das ist
der hier in cremiger Rahmsoße und diese
Soße könnt ihr verwenden entweder für
Nudeln oder zum Beispiel für Pfannkuchen
oder einfach so allein stehen für alle
anderen Gerichte Spargel in cremiger
Soße das ist der Renner ich zeige euch
mal kurz die Zutaten ihr benötigt dafür
40 g Butter eine weiße Zwiebel 40g Mehl
400g Wasser 400 g Milch zwei Esslöffel
gemüsebrühpaste das ist die
selbstgemachte ich habe noch etwas
Zitronensaft und Muskat zum Abschmecken
einen Kilo Spargel der ist bereits
geschält und wenn ihr benötigt noch
gerne etwas Salz und Pfeffer ich werde
jetzt definitiv benötigen also beim
Spargel einfach nur drauf achten eine
super Qualität verwenden am besten
regionalen Spargel am besten von eurem
Bauern oder eure Bäuerin aus der Region
ich habe den jetzt auch schon schälen
lassen denn was ich einfach nicht mehr
mache ist Spargel selber schälen die
Bauern die haben einfach direkt eine
spargelschälmaschine man spart sich ein
Haufen Zeit und die Masterarbeit die man
dadurch eben nicht hat deswegen direkt
geschälten Spargeln ein Kilo geschältes
Gewicht und ich habe hier meine Samira
Pfanne die kann ich jetzt gleich
erwärmen da kann ich nämlich schon mal
die Butter reingeben denn zuerst machen
wir jetzt so was wie eine Mehlschwitze
aber mit Zwiebeln also die Butter
einfach auf mittlere Hitze erwärmen und
die Zwiebel in Würfel schneiden
und dann gebt ihr die Zwiebelwürfel zur
Butter dazu und schwenkt sie darin für
etwa drei bis vier Minuten gerne auch
mit Deckel damit hier in der Umgebung
nicht so sehr nach Zwiebel duftet
in der Zeit dürft ihr dann gerne schon
mal euren geschälten Spargel schneiden
hier vorne ist er der Spargelkopf und
der ist immer schneller gar und
schneller weich das bedeutet den gebe
ich am Anfang nicht mit dazu denn das
was hier hinten ist so der Spargel an
sich der braucht ein bisschen länger als
der Spargelkopf und ich schneide es
jetzt hier einfach schon mal in
mundgerechte Stücke
etwa drei bis vier cm
ich bin ein bisschen
angeht deswegen habe ich ja dieses Wände
Brett denn auf der Murat Seite das ist
die Herz auf der Seite schneide ich
herzhafte Zutaten für zwiebel Knoblauch
oder Gemüse und auf der Sally Seite wird
nur Obst und Süßes geschnitten damit am
Ende die Erdbeere nicht nach Zwiebel
schmeckt oder die Ananas nach Knoblauch
wenn sie jetzt lecker duften und lecker
aussehen kommt das Mehl dazu denn jetzt
wird die Mehlschwitze gemacht und dann
gerne mit Wasser oder auch mit Weißwein
ablöschen ist noch die Milch dazugeben
ich würde das ganze jetzt mit meiner
gemüsebrühpaste da habt ihr das Rezept
schon auf meinem Kanal dann kommt noch
Salz Pfeffer und Muskat dazu ein
bisschen Zitronensaft und wenn ihr wollt
dass die Zwiebeln stückig sind lasst ihr
das ganze so wenn ihr das nicht wollt
und lieber eine cremige Soße haben wollt
dann einfach durchrühren
und normalerweise muss man seine Soße
das ist so eine Art Bechamelsoße so 5
bis 10 Minuten köcheln lassen ich mache
das aber gleich direkt mit dem Spargel
darin denn dann kann der schön Gas
ziehen also kommen jetzt die
Spargelstücke dazu
und da müsste jetzt mal schauen je
nachdem wie dick sie sind brauchen sie
jetzt darin so etwa 5 bis 10 Minuten ihr
probiert dann einfach mal einen Spargel
und schaut dann und kurz vor Ende der
Garzeit etwa 2 Minuten davor gehen wir
noch die Spargelköpfe dazu und lassen
uns dann einfach nur noch kurz
durchziehen und in der Zwischenzeit
könnt ihr jetzt gerne Nudeln abkochen
Pfannkuchen zubereiten super Pfannkuchen
solltet ihr vorher machen denn die
brauchen länger als diese fünf Minuten
und dann könnt ihr das ganze gerne
servieren jetzt hier einfach schön bei
niedriger Stufe köcheln lassen mit
Deckel
und so zieht der Spargelgeschmack dann
nämlich auch wunderbar in die Soße
freue mich
[Musik]
es darf mal der Murat probieren meinen
leckeren weißen Spargel in cremiger
rahmensoße
wollte ich nur sagen ja aber was will
ich jetzt mal ganz ehrlich da falsch
machen
coole Pfannkuchen Spargel frische
Spargel außen Region wir sind die
Spargel Region in Deutschland baden und
der kommt von unserem Kumpel den Bauer
Klaus aus Reinigen der wahrscheinlich
beste spargelauer der Welt ja und hast
du Bärlauch auch noch oder
warte mal kurz aus dem Kühlschrank
so also wenn ihr jetzt die Rahmen
Spargel
mit Nudeln zubereitet dann wirklich die
Soße zubereiten Spargel rein dann die
Nudeln abkochen und am besten ganz
frisch die Nudeln dann damit vermengen
in der großen Pfanne das mache ich jetzt
nicht denn wir probieren Sie gleich noch
mit dem Pfannkuchen oh das ist da und
wenn ihr wollt natürlich noch ein
bisschen Bärlauchpesto drauf wenn ihr da
habt den haben wir übrigens den Nussloch
gesammelt aber ich verrate euch die
Stelle nicht weil sonst nichts mehr doch
es gibt genug
aber Bärlauch Timer
aus der Region werden
wenn du im Restaurant
ganz kurze Geschichte erzählen und zwar
habe
wenn du dein Teller zu voll machst dann
kann es sein dass Du nachher Steuern
nach zahlen musst weil das Finanzamt
sagt du hast über portioniert
ohne Spaß wenn du zu volle Teller machst
kommt ins Finanzamt sagt immer zu du
hast
so habe ich beim da gibt es schon auf
auf Instagram gibt so ein Restaurant Typ
Coach heißt der glaube das erzählt die
Keller nicht zu voll machen und
irgendwie hat er mit ich habe es nicht
verstanden alles klar war schön mit Euch
fertig tut mir leid nämlich noch den
Pfannkuchen hier habe nämlich
vorgestellt dass ich schwöre euch
so
darf ich noch mal was sagen ja die fünf
meist ich habe gerade Blubber Wasser
getrunken glaube ich
die fünf meistgesuchtesten Rezepte auf
Google ich ich verarsche jetzt echt
nicht die Pfeife Sachen
ich denke immer an irgendwas besonderes
Rezepte gewesen wirklich die deutschen
suchen nach Pfannkuchen
oder das ist auch mal kurz
stand auf Jahrmarkt
umso dreckiger
Wasser getrunken glaube ich nee also
Wasser
denn ich liebe auch Spargel mit
Pfannkuchen holländisch
wenn es nicht möglich einfach Nutella
rein machen
so macht man das einfach
er schafft immer wieder aus Sallys fünf
Minuten Sallys 50 Minuten aber
lieber so als andersrum und falls euch
das Rezept gefällt schreibt gerne in die
Kommentare
und ich würde mich freuen wenn ihr es
nachmacht sag mir doch gerne mal wozu
ihr euren weißen Spargel in Ramses
serviert Pfannkuchen Nudeln einfach so
ich habe keine weitere rede ich habe
keine Freunde mehr genommen
ja aber ich rede gerne mit euch also sie
baut nicht denken dass es ich so ein
okay
www.blog.de oder eine App die ist
übrigens kostenlos und werbefrei mal
ganz coole Funktion einfach Sallys App
ja super hervorragend oder kommt unsere
Restaurant weil wir machen vielleicht
demnächst auf einmal ein bisschen
gerüchtig freuen
uns Vorschläge schreiben also mach's gut
bis zum nächsten Mal
besuchen wir könnten miteinander reden
so ein Stammtisch machen ein paar
aber dann so
dass man dort brunchen kann
Cola Mittagstisch schönes Abendessen am
Abend Bar mit Karaoke natürlich da bin
ich mein eigener Stammgast und dann hat
es nachts zu weil nach Kaffee machen wir
nicht und am nächsten morgen geht's dann
wieder
loslassen
nicht geplant gehabt
brauchst du es gar nicht mehr
dann ist es komplett egal tschüss
[Musik]